we're gonna jump into the first segment
and we're all I'll I'm so happy I want
to make fun of celebrities I hate these
people and Ryan Reynolds does such a
wonderful job they're making fun of them
with us it's great so so first from the
Washington Examiner Ryan Reynolds mocks
celebrities for coronavirus messages
quote I think we all know that it's the
celebrities that we count on most I
don't so I gotta take it back I don't
hate all celebrities right I'm being a
little I'm exaggerating a little bit cuz
Ryan Reynolds is a celebrity and he's
one of the best for four reasons like
this dragging down these narcissistic
arrogant elitists yeah who think they're
better than you and they know it to
quote Globo gym but it's fun yeah you
remember that fright from dodgeball no
Ben Stiller's character was like we here
at Globo gym we're better than you and
we know it that's not that's not what
that's what I think whenever I see any
one of these celebrities post their
stupid messages relate to you know it's
like they think they're better than you
and and look I'm not trying to imply
that celebrities are literally sitting
there like smoking cigars going like man
what a bunch of morons
ha but they're they're actually like you
know they think of it I am here's how I
feel these celebrities view the rest of
people as moronic children okay like
dumb kids and so they're like wouldn't
it be so cool everyone would love it if
we all sang together and did the
celebrity thing and so we did rag on
them for singing that cursed song
yeah the cursed version of imagine I
haven't still haven't heard it duh you
don't want to I haven't I haven't done
it I don't
my ears are precious to me dude you know
it's what's what's really crazy is that
is that the corona virus has really
exposed how these people are talentless
like maybe talent this is the wrong word
okay but they really do rely on these
big machines to make them special seem
better
cuz think about someone like Ryan
Reynolds okay he shines like he does
this he does his own like he did that
commercial with the peloton woman you
see that one no so do you know the
peloton commercial thing that went viral
no I don't know it was this cursed
commercial where this woman like comes
home and her husband buys of the peloton
bike which is it's an exercise Michael
with the iPad basically thought it is
sure and it was this really awful
commercial so it goes viral have been
ragging on it Ryan Reynolds immediately
calls up her agent or whatever and says
I wanted to do a commercial for my gin
company and the the commercial was just
slowly zooming out from her face with
this look on her face where she's like
kind of just like because she's being
rag Don yeah and her friends are like
you're safe here and then shoot and then
she like chugs her her gin and tonic or
whatever yeah and then the other woman
goes like okay and she slides her over
another one so like Ryan Reynolds this
dude's a legit genius yeah like I don't
I don't use the word genius to mean like
he's a math you know mathematical whiz
or a scientist ya know he's like an
expert in his craft he's funny poka
charismatic yeah he really is so he
nails it but then you can look at a lot
of these other people and they really
have no idea what they're doing
yeah like case in point is you got to
see this video man I think this is it
I'm not trying to be mean but Trevor
Noah trying to do his show so this is
like Stephen Colbert did this oh god
they're doing these these yeah from home
from home videos in his tub he was in
his tub he was in his bathtub was he
really like no he was wearing a full
suit though bubbles and everything at
that I appreciate yeah that's funny but
one of the things that he did is like in
his backyard he does this like sitting
by the fire pit oh and it's just like
wow man you have to see how how they
really don't have anything to them the
next factor if you will yeah I don't you
know it's crazy is I'm a youtuber okay
we you know I sit around and I rant at
the camera on YouTube you are now a
youtuber podcast I am a youtuber now but
I didn't even think about that but think
about I'm a youtuber but think about
this think about why I made it in life
think about how people are watching us
and we do this routinely yeah and you
can see the set we have we put work into
it
once they lose access to the machine the
network like Trevor Noah is just sitting
in front of his shelf that he didn't
even like what do you do what is what
shelf is this are those cabinets like it
really feels like they have no idea what
to do but look at there's quality coffee
table books man Wow well yeah this is
like what is this I don't know I see
Peter Limburg wild beautiful places he's
so classy
with his confident it's just what what
we're seeing now with actually quite
nice
they're trying there's not a hi there
pretty I like flowers
it's it just it's really amazing for me
to see that you know I worked for a big
studio I work for a big you know Network
yeah and I'm capable of making a regular
video in my house and making it look
well like making it look good I'm gonna
have to they can't improve of like what
my YouTube videos yeah no make a make a
video that you know out in the house not
in your studio well I made tons of them
dude I made a bunch of vacuum anything
I've been shortlisted for a bunch of
awards yeah yeah man we stiii used to do
full-length documentary stuff okay and
then when I would need to do so I've
been pitching to all these big companies
like you need to hybridize you need to
be able to produce on the fly at home
home studios look what they're doing
it's like once they lose access to the
studio it's like so Donald Trump hmm
said yeah and then everyone it's like
yeah you're right
like no teleprompter what's going on no
teleprompter no laugh track and it's all
just it's Joba I'm not all over again
yes so anyway tell me what to say tell
me what to say so anyway here's here's
what what Ryan Reynolds said right now
actually I wonder if I can play the
video it's gonna work if I play it well
Thank You Prime Minister Trudeau we need
to work together to flatten the curve
and fight off kovin 19 I think in times
of crisis I think we all know that it's
it's the it's the celebrities that we
count on most they're the ones who are
gonna get us through this right after
health care workers of course first
responders people work in essential
services ping pong players mannequins
childhood imaginary friends
sure like 400 other types of people look
stay at home social distancing wash your
hands we are gonna get through this
thing wring it through this thing
together and I'd like to nominate these
three great Canadians to spread the word
mr. Stephen Paige
constable Terry Reynolds of the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police and mr. Seth
Rogan of the
Point Grey Rogen's point gray Rogan what
does that mean so that was that was
funny anyway you know is great and I
love that he's doing it take none of
these people cuz we now we're gonna jump
into BuzzFeed
I love BuzzFeed I mean that's
facetiously the nineteen most tone-deaf
thing celebrities have said or done
about coronavirus if I see another
celebrity complaining about quarantine
and their huge mansion one more time I
swear to God met I completely agree a
guy who wrote the the listicle artwork
compiled it yeah and so I started I
started reading the list I had to stop
because it was so funny yeah so I don't
know we're gonna see in this list of out
of touch
insane celebrities but let's just jump
into it Oh Jamie Dornan I've I've worked
with him before
who's that where he's the guy from Fifty
Shades of Grey oh right well why was he
somebody oh that's right he was singing
that song no gal gadot and a bunch of
very rich people saying imagine from
they're very rich houses we did we did
talk about that right we don't need to
play that no definitely not treasure my
tears the celebrity singing imagined to
us poor commonfolk during a pandemic oh
Vanessa Hudgens made a really stupid
video where she asked why the
coronavirus is such a big deal who's
that I don't know who is she she's a
she's if she was a child star which
probably explains some of her weirdness
yeah there you go I love this one thing
as MC yeah oh man so first I think C is
great I think music I think she's one of
the best singers but this we live right
now she's incredible see you posted this
dumb confusing drawing that means
literally I have no idea she scratched
up fear and it says us I love this look
at this sweet it's finally over guys we
can come out I love it yeah thank you
very much
corn that's great oh man we're cured
I like the corn one alright here we go
oh what is this dude I just ruin my day
what what why Botox out of existence wow
she really is what happened to her
Madonna called the coronavirus the great
equalizer from a bathtub sprinkled with
rose petals dude hold on do you guys I
don't even recognize who that is
didn't say it was Madonna I would not
have been able to tell you that right
happened do you have any rich friends
have you like grew up with like some
rich friends yeah I know you meet
Pokemon but I'm talking about growing up
do you know like did you grow up with no
we're just completely out of time out on
the south side of Chicago I never nobody
no but I I met some people you know
around the time of like Occupy Wall
Street and they just don't get it it's
this it's them being like have the maid
do it you know what I mean yes like
being so out of touch no those people
always annoyed me I feel bad you wanna
get the vibe around those kind of people
and I don't like the vibe that they send
off you know like let other people do it
I don't like it I like getting my own
thing I like to handle my own business
you know take care of my own stuff it's
not it's not so much about you know
being responsible for yourself it's
about their so out of touch if they
think you could hire maids yeah it's
like why don't you just tell your mates
it's like because that cost a lot of
money
yeah because expense or it's like or
actually it's like one-time mates but
I'm actually a house cleaner that's what
I do for a living like they don't
understand it's actually really funny
comment I don't I don't who's it from is
this was it Colin noir is that his name
the : yeah and he said I think it was
him who said this that the the gun
control arguments are the equivalent of
like saying have them made do it are the
self-defense equivalent of saying have
the maid do it people who live in like
cities with access to resources and
police departments things that you know
rural folk don't have yeah you end up
well so I don't want to go off on a
tangent but looking at this stuff of
like Madonna calling it the great
equalizer when she's so far removed from
reality and has no idea what regular
people deal with but this is what's
scary these people with tons of money
yeah think they know and then they go
out and invest and spend that money on
politics to make things happen that have
no real bearing on like regular people
I'm pretty sure I saw a twit tweeters
with the whatever Twitter yeah there we
go a tweet that Madonna actually did
like some you know music video in her
house with just like a phone someone was
like recording with some sort of light
yeah and she was just singing she's lost
it I just I just quickly scrolled right
past I was
no can't do it no no no so no remember
what I was saying about like child
actors yeah so you know for those that
may have missed it basically the point I
made when you're a little kid and
everyone in the world is telling you
you're telling you you're the best and
you're you're famous and you're a star
and they love you
mm-hmm it feels like that's normal yeah
and when you start from that position as
you grow up you're trying to improve and
do better but you can't do better than
world-famous as one of these you know
child actors or actresses so the same
thing as musicians Yeah right right
right the same thing is true for people
who get famous at any point let's say
you know Madonna was famous at a young
age and now she's getting older and it's
literally impossible for her to improve
her standing because Jordana
yeah but she's also losing her appeal in
a la virgen ways and no I don't just
mean her looks like she you know
injected her face full of Botox or
whatever would she have weird but it's
also that she's just not a relevant
singer her music isn't relevant her
personality isn't yeah and so now
they're struggling and they go crazy
they start trying to do whatever they
can you know throwing bongs out windows
or starting fires and driveways what did
that happen that was Amanda Bynes yeah
when she was like in her 20s and she
like she was a so I don't know the full
story you know the media loves to spend
things but apparently she threw a bong
out the window in Times Square something
like that I don't know kind of hurts the
motive and then she got arrested for
setting a fire in her neighbor's
driveway I guess I don't know if that's
all true because you know how the media
likes to play games oh yeah amanda Bynes
oh yeah you also to be careful because
you never know who's litigious yeah here
we go Lionel Richie said he wants to
make a new we are the world for kovat 19
because it's exactly what we need no no
no oh here you go we got Jennifer Lopez
continuously makes us feel poor by
posting videos in her parasite like home
we can't to go out to any restaurants or
anything but the service an
entertainment here is pretty good well I
can't really be mad at her for I mean a
being rich kid bringing her some drinks
like that's kind of cute yeah and and
just because she's rich like she's not
like trying to pander to anybody she's
just making a little gag video from her
house so yeah I'll give her a pass on
that one it's not so bad and look it's
ridiculously large and football field
Wow
yeah okay
okay here we go don't be jealous I love
our backyard we got a pretty dumb
backyard this priyanka chopra clap from
a balcony at a huge empty yard
what is she clapping on I don't know
play we're gonna find out what she did
it's got almost 2 million views she's
clapping for the people around the world
this is because people around the world
have shown their appreciation for the
doctors nurses and first responders so
she's clapping for all the all the
people all the real heroes out there but
to her backyard this is the point I was
making out to the camera no no knocking
- hey actually this is the pointer Oh
that's watching this is the point was
making off you you take away their team
and then there's hollow shells
yeah dude there was this really viral
video for my ten years ago where they
were like how to make a pop star mm-hmm
and they basically just took beautiful
women okay that couldn't sing yeah
auto-tuned everything and they show you
exactly how they do it at the end they
made like a snippet of like a pop star
music video yeah they were like it's all
fake you take these these women you know
that they use as like pop stars and
they're talentless not all of them you
know the ones that are really talented
end up going really really far I know
some models that they were attractive
and they were like oh man I got I got
this producer he's gonna do this thing
for me I mean this is guys and girls you
know not just talking girls but like
none of them could sing I was just like
oh gosh I've heard you sing no please no
matter no but they're like yeah but I'm
gonna go places there I haven't heard
anything from them since this that time
you know that's like 10 years ago
I think that's like a work ethic thing
if you were to ask me really I think
it's an issue of if you work hard enough
and you and you and you you keep digging
you know you'll you'll get to where you
need to go even if you're not a good
musician yes if you work hard enough as
a musician you'll make it somewhere yep
dude have you ever have you listened to
like who's that guy
who like he's the rapper who Auto Tunes
literally everything he says Drake
no no no no I don't know the guys name
when you like popularized heavy Auto
tuning so it sounds like you're a robot
but the point of what I'm making is
people like his music yeah even though
he's not good vocally
hey men figure out figure works for him
it's kind of like you know if you're not
tall enough to reach the top shelf you
you get a stool you put on some stilts
now you can reach it right I'm sure so
if your voice is terrible then you hire
people to prop you up or more
importantly a lot of these people are
just models it's like you get an
attractive guy or an attractive woman
and you're like I need you to say this
and they go okay so like you know Trevor
no you put him from a teleprompter any
talks yeah what is in front of a camera
with no teleprompter in his house and
it's like but even that was still partly
scripted you know okay
so I'll tell you see it's I don't I
don't know if it's good or bad I don't
know here's how you see talent right
Ryan Reynolds films a little video
hilarious yeah that's true these these
night out like nightly holidays struggle
in their bed what's one minute long and
it was great super easy it's not like he
was hosting a show like these other
people are actually hosting their show
and it's Enterprise 5 minute long yep
like an actual show it's like you should
I think you should prep for that you
know yeah not that we prepped very much
all right let's see what BuzzFeed's got
for us Idris Elba's wife decided to take
the corona test even though the tests
are in short supply and she knew her
husband at it and she tested positive I
don't know there wasn't there there
people have been complaining all like
non-stop that it's really difficult to
get a test yeah and they want to know in
case their risk is gonna go up and the
gut like these hospitals saying we're
saving it for people that we need to
know for sure right so I honestly find
it weird because the people who aren't
showing symptoms are the ones who
actually need the tests like if you got
the symptoms you probably got it lets
you know if your symptoms get worse we
take the hospital right yeah or
quarantine yourself if you're sick
anyway like if you're sick don't go out
yeah you really only need to go to the
hospital if you start getting the I
don't remember the stuff that that forms
in your lungs but that's that's what's
causing you not to be able to breathe
and that's when it becomes a problem
they need to go to the hospital
look at this Drake Drake tried to make
us feel bad for his quarantine situation
by showing his private full-sized
basketball court smile he said my life
for the next however long oh poor poor
Drake what is this Wow like a movie now
this is showing off
yeah it's like what yeah is it so for
those that are listening is hey hey
that's a lie I posted a picture of my my
skateboard when I was about to drop in
and I little showing off a little bit
like this is what I'm doing right now
you're you are a out of touch to Liberty
yet
I guess I am but I own that ramp though
like that here's our floor bow our floor
bow oh the floor bow brave documented
floor bows break down so I do wanna make
sure I explain the floor bow thing
people who don't get it of course so you
know Sam Smith has come out as
non-binary and floorball wants you to
use floor bows pronouns well I I won't
use words that other people tell me I
have to use these remember what I want
but I tell me what to do what but I will
respect floor bows desire not to be
misgendered right so I will use the
pronoun floor bow for anybody who uses
an atypical pronoun for one simple
reason some people might be offended by
if I was to say they you know if some
came you and said I want you to affirm
me as they someone else it's offensive
to me so how do I avoid offending
everybody
floor bow yep it just rolls off the
tongue it's meant to be it's meant to be
a soft inoffensive sound floor bow floor
both brought so so anyway Sam Smith
documented floor bells break down the
dude was break down the floor bow yes no
women are dudes to the dude was crying
you know I can't do the pronoun thing
I'm sorry Sam Smith was crying in his
house he documented his breakdown
because he's a guy and he'd like you
listen man I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
go there oh no I can't just say like oh
by the way I'm non-binary it's like dude
you've got a beard and you're like a guy
like you're wearing you're doing nothing
to be non-bio you can't just he kind of
man like the chubby floor bow Justin
Timberlake in these pictures
Justin's a dude yo floor bow look man
there's a difference between someone
who's actually trans you know or you
know is experiencing Dysport or
something and you're asking for a simple
respect it's another thing if you're one
of these trendy dudes jumping on the
bandwagon
yeah that you're just like oh by the way
from now on you
we have to call me that it's like I
actually don't and I'm not gonna throw
anything right have to call me this but
you can get banned from Twitter for it
really yeah if you miss Jenna so uh
there's a rapper named zoobi okay and
you responded someone okay dude and they
suspended him and now I know I actually
follow through but right now he's got
shirts that okay dude yep here we go
Bella Hadid told us to stay inside while
she ate a burrito topless what wait wait
here we go what's the point
Katie oh look at this Katy Perry posted
a fake video of Italian singing roar
from their balconies fake now was that
her just promoting her song roar is one
of her videos Jamie King made a bizarre
video thanking the coronavirus like the
literal virus for bringing people
together these people are not span what
Thanks these people are crazy this is
incredible I love it
oh not Evangeline Lilly no she bragged
about not socially this I don't know
really half of these people are
seriously she's she's the wasp from oh
yeah I never knew her Nana yeah cool
right just dropped my kids off at
gymnastics camp they all washed their
hands for going in there playing and
laughing business as usual in gymnastics
camp where everyone's flipping around in
sweating wedding and like grabbing
handlebars yeah that's smart here we go
what Jennifer Aniston posted a picture
of her dog having deep thoughts while
quarantine Arnold Schwarzenegger told us
to social distance from his jacuzzi
while smoking a cigar notice there's a
better one he's sitting on his couch and
he's got this little tiny dog sitting
next to him that's cute and he's like
Edie don't be like I don't remember the
dog's name because the the mini donkey
walks up to him and the little dog like
goes whoa whoa slow down don't be like
the little dog be like the donkey Oh
Mike that was amazing like what did I
just watch so wait are you putting out
some good stuff I got
yes something better oh yeah he has a
donkey it's an actually I think it's a
mini horse like little Sebastian from
Parks and Rec I don't know if you guys
are Parks and Rec fan that sounds
amazing
so some celebrities are doing it right I
got it give it to shorts and Egger
started a foundation and he's donating
half a million dollars to medical
supplies Wow
so he's got my I already was all about
what Arnold is doing there's a little
horse really I'm not sure on the second
one but I know he's not one Kylie Jenner
revealed that staying in the house for
months while she was pregnant which is
totally relatable prepared her for the
quarantine whoo all right I was kidding
she's one she's one of these probably
know who she is
they're famous for being famous yeah or
having someone who's famous in their
family cool I'm on day eight my
pregnancy prepared me for this I didn't
leave the house for months
Alon what have you done he changed his
tune mokona virus panic is dumb yeah one
he did change the factory into making
risk hold on he's not wrong the panic
that's true and I think people are just
trying to drag him because he said the
panic was done but dude he's right the
panic is done okay dumb people are dumb
that's true as well there was a there's
there I'm going to narrate for all of
you a meme ooh it was hilarious go on it
was on Twitter when people talk about
the krona virus the top was grandpa what
did you do during the great coronavirus
pandemic and he said I had a very
dangerous job I was a tail gunner for a
Sharman shipping truck oh my god and the
picture is a truck with 12 paper on the
side and a mounted tail gun like 50 cals
pretty good so yes I really wanted that
to be true the panic is done I gotta
agree with you on this one
BuzzFeed no it's not okay you know Elon
was right the panic is insane people
rushing in to fight over toilet paper
yeah it's but now but now apparently
like you were saying you know people who
don't have any yeah I got a I got a
buddy of mine out in Arizona it looks
like I don't have anything
I don't have any toilet paper I didn't
stock up and now there's no toilet paper
anywhere he goes he's like straight up
goes what is it every store to find
toilet paper and I love like well yeah
because everywhere hanok but everything
else is available when when we went to
the store and that and and I I felt like
a king moseying on through the bean
aisle yeah with with no obstruction in
sight and beans galore and we loaded up
our cart with all of the variety of the
sea truth there was that no one in the
food aisles no I mean think about that
there's like a lone straggler here right
here but not really but we even got this
little bag it's really great it's it's
it's called what does it called like a
bean medley it's a variety of I love a
variety of beans yet when we went to the
toilet paper aisle it was stripped bare
like still people in there thinking they
were like you know they were doing this
yeah dude yeah maybe I'll find some if I
look a little harder so I just I just
thought of a great expectation versus
reality mean the expectation in the you
know apocalypse ambi apocalypse is like
zombies fighting people and people
running and the reality is the zombies
rushing the toilet paper aisle while
other people are shrugging like what are
you doing that zombies they they survive
on toilet paper
maybe all right here's the big finale
Kim Kardashian tried to tell us to take
social distancing seriously even though
she wasn't socially distancing herself
is that it well the first ones were
funny and it kind of went downhill makes
sense though thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you